a Louisiana school board is under fire
after a teacher was forcibly removed
from a board meeting after questioning
the superintendent's Pay Daysha Hargrave
was handcuffed and arrested by a city
marshal Monday night in Abbeville that
is west of New Orleans the middle school
English teacher was booked on one count
of resisting an officer and one count of
remaining on premises after forbidden
while she later posted bond vladimir
duthiers our streaming network cbsn is
here Vlad good morning good morning it's
a disturbing story Parish School Board
and and City prosecutors say they are
not moving forward with charges against
Hargrave but many in the district still
want to know why their colleague a
former Teacher of the Year was arrested
in the first place just minutes after
telling the Vermillion Parish School
Board that teachers are scared of
speaking out Dasia Hargrave was arrested
at the board meeting Monday night
Hargrave had expressed frustration with
the plan to give the superintendent a
raise
upwards of $35,000 a deputy city marshal
stepped in to escort Hargrave out but
moments later she's heard screaming from
the hall
superintendent Jerome Pio is not
commenting on Hargreaves arrest but is
defending his raise it was time that we
brought to the board a salary that was
commensurate with what superintendents
I'm making since 2012 Pio has been
making around 110 thousand dollars a
year according to two board members with
the new contract that was approved
Monday he could earn thirty-eight
thousand more in 2016 the average
Louisiana teacher's salary was around
forty nine thousand dollars board member
laural above says teachers in the
district haven't had a raise in a decade
and called the treatment of Hargrave
disgusting
the way that females are treated in
foreign powers
before President Anthony Fontana is
defending the city Marshalls actions a
board member was recognized and the
board members getting ready to speak
when she cut into him
that's when the officer acted and I
think he acted probably the city
prosecutor says the marshal was a school
resource officer employed by the school
board and not associated with the city
of Abbeville the ACLU of Louisiana says
it's investigating the incident teachers
in the district plan to hold a rally
supporting Hargrave on Thursday as you
can imagine for former Teacher of the
Year it's a big deal and yeah I'm
paraphrasing the New York Times reporter
Nicole Hannah Jones who says our
children know how we value them by the
schools we built for them the teachers
that we pay in the story that errol did
in baltimore these are important stories
i think somebody needs some new glasses
if they think that was the appropriate
way to handle that and I think mr.
Marshall man needs some training
regardless because she was clearly
leaving when she was a constant that way
it's very disturbing you see you know
it's unfortunate that she was arrested
but in some ways this is bringing
attention yes to a really important
story the teachers haven't had a raise
in a decade or maybe this will lead to
some change
superintendent gonna have to earn his is
raised in handling this issue
thank you very much glad